New York magazine national correspondent
Gabriel DeBenedetti joins us Gabe
good morning so a lot happened this week
yes okay but the Republicans insist
there was no bombshell irrelevant
testimony just a big sham what impact
especially with David Holmes coming out
did this testimony in these hearings
give ya well I think that's obviously
beyond the Republican line from the
start that this is going to be a sham
that this was all hearsay but what we
saw this week was a number of credible
witnesses who have some personal
knowledge of the various policy changes
that were happening in Ukraine and in
some cases were the subject of
intimidation from the president I think
one of the you know one of the things
that we're going to see in the next few
days of course is people who did have
first-hand knowledge of the various
calls that we're discussing speaking out
in public and that is going to have to
change a little bit the Republican line
on it and that's David Holmes in
particular talk about him what we're
gonna see in his testimony yeah we found
out from this letter that's right well
David Holmes was the one of the people
who was directly privy to the call that
we learned about this week from
ambassador Bill Taylor between the
President and Gordon Sandlin the
ambassador to the European Union about
trying to pressure Ukraine Holmes is
essentially corroborating the idea that
President Trump was directly involved
with directing the service because he
says he heard the conversation because
the president was so loud he was on the
phone with sunrise but because he was so
loud he heard the conversation X right
and we will also be hearing from Solomon
this week and Alexander vind Minh the
national security council expert who of
course was also on the line for the
other phone call that we've been talking
and possibly a few others that's right
what about this remarkable moment where
the president tweeted and then Adam
Schiff was reading and asking for a
response from ambassador Jovanovic have
any Republicans spoken out yet to defend
the president's tweeting well I think
what you've seen from a lot of
Republicans is essentially saying let's
not talk about the process here let's
talk about the actual substance of
what's happening it's in many ways a
deflection but what you saw a very
interesting thing from a lot of
Democrats they're essentially talking
about this the president's tweets in
real time as a potential new line of
inquiry in the impeachment process of
potential new article of impeachment
just because of that tweet obviously
we've never seen anything like that
before does Gordon Sunland potentially
have to turn on the president's yeah
well it depends what we mean by
but that is definitely whatever one in
Washington is asking right now he's been
a staunch ally of the president but he's
changed his testimony over the last two
weeks to say I recall more and more that
does sound sort of incriminating towards
President Trump we'll see the full
extent of it
and on the heels of this hearing yeah
Roger stone that's right being convicted
that's right yet another one of the
president's close associates now likely
going to prison for a long time
obviously not something that the White
House is looking forward to talking
about but potentially banking in a
pardon yeah that's right all right good
thanks very much thank you